and everything that you've uncovered
with these Satanic rituals and
everything at the um the one place up in
California Bohemian Grove and this you
talked about they're praying to the
devil and they're sacrificing the
children and everything like this do you
feel like it's just a fight of believing
in God
versus the doubt 100 is that what it
comes down to yeah archetypes I mean for
people that are you know I'm not gonna
try to just push nothing but
Christianity people but that's that's
what I believe that's what I know but
absolutely the first step is to realize
there is good and evil there's stuff we
don't see there's other dimensions and
none of these globalists are atheists
they're all under the occult they're all
into weirdness they're all super
neurotic and uh or they're super scared
of God I just don't want to hear about
it like Rupert Murdoch